police are investigating the first case
of rape in the metaverse according to
prosecutors a child a girl under the age
of 16 was attacked in a virtual reality
video game and she was left distraught
after her Avatar was gang raped by
strangers online now the report goes on
to make clear that the girl did not
suffer any physical injuries obviously
she's just wearing a headset in a video
game but prosecutors say she suffered
emotional injuries and they're going to
investigate this as some kind of sexual
crime and a lot of conservatives are
making fun of this they're saying are
you kidding me she should have just
taken the headset off are you kidding me
it's just a video game grow up no crime
took place to which I say that's the
most liberal take I've ever heard are
you kidding me of you you think that the
only kind of crime that can take place
is a physical crime that what we do
online is is morally neutral that we
shouldn't be held accountable for what
we do on are you kidding that's what the
libs think that's not what the
conservatives think